drive through western siberia and you
pass one oil installation after the next
in the swampy ground the pipelines which
form the veins and arteries of russia's
economy
this is oil and gas central russian
hydrocarbons for delivery worldwide and
not much sense of the climate emergency
russian energy giant rosneft has
facilities everywhere it's their key oil
producing region and everywhere we see
flares
that's methane burnt off rather than
stored or reprocessed
it's not as bad as releasing it pure but
still it's a major source of co2 with
quite a bit of methane still mixed in
rosneft has promised to end all flaring
by 2030 as part of an impressive
sounding sustainability strategy
but that is still a long way from
reality and that's really russia's story
with so much oil gas and coal still to
extract for decades to come
what will those promises look like in 10
20 30 years time
pipes laid in soviet times now rusting
no longer in use the evidence of past
oil spills still plain to see across
scarred earth and dead trees
but then there are the leaks that we
cannot see
methane escaping from damaged pipes or
faulty storage tanks or vented
deliberately at huge environmental cost
rosneft's local securities stop us at a
checkpoint and then tail us for hours
not keen on us filming even from public
roads
why are you following us all the time
russia is the number one flaring culprit
by far and you can see that from the
satellite data this tool from flare
analytics firm capterio can track any
flare anywhere and measure its emissions
yeah so they're inventing and leaking
put together for rushes probably of the
order of 1.4 billion co2 equivalent tons
so that's
equivalent to probably about 50 million
u.s passenger vehicles being taken off
the road by solving this problem
petrochemical companies like sibor
provide one solution taking these gases
and processing them turning them into
polymers which are the feedstock for
plastics
[Music]
ah
is a green pioneer setting out ambitious
climate targets and investing heavily in
low carbon technologies
but if russia is to hit net zero by 2060
the rest of the country needs to catch
up
[Music]
in the oil capital surgut we meet some
young recruits for the local oil firm on
a team building exercise pretending to
be oil pumps
they aren't too worried about our
warming planet
can you imagine a russia without oil and
gas
but the methane leaks from russia's oil
and gas industry are just a fraction of
what we burn using the energy that it
produces
and if global demand stays strong the
sun setting on russian hydrocarbons
looks like it's a long long way off
down to
magnesium siberia